what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Brad Garlin house is the
CEO of ripple in this conversation we
discussed what ripple does how XRP is
related the current progress to date and
then Brad answers a number of hard
questions that were crowd-sourced from
Twitter this conversation has been
highly anticipated so I want to make a
few things clear up front
Brad participated in this podcast
episode without he or his team reviewing
my questions beforehand there was no
payment of any kind that exchanged hands
and the episode has not been edited in
any material way other than the removal
of prolonged silences or filler words
like uh or um when I agreed to record
this episode I figured that both
supporters and detractors of ripple or
XRP would be unhappy with the final
product that is okay with me
I spent quite a bit of time preparing
for this interview including talking to
people from both sides along with
crowdsourcing a lot of questions that
people wanted answered I hope you listen
to this episode with an open mind and
walk away thinking the conversation was
fair and balanced either way I hope you
enjoy it
want to know who has the best URL crypto
calm that's right
crypto calm there crypto platform with
one goal mother and mass adoption that's
why we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out tell them pomp sent
you download the app or visit crypto
calm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
calm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the
lack they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them Tom sent you and thank me
later as many of you know crypto
investors store their digital assets on
exchanges or in cold storage for long
term safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now securely store their Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency six percent is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pump again
that's block 5 com / pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto you've probably heard
of eToro they're the world's number one
social trading platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it - and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin aetherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks at eternal calm again that's
eToro comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp lion-o
is a partner at Morgan Creek Digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of more digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational
versus only alright guys bang-bang super
excited about this episode I think we
broke the internet before you even got
here
um I've got Brad here who we are going
to try to get through a whole bunch of
information and hopefully when people
leave here they will understand his
perspective on how ripple XRP works kind
of let him describe where they are from
a progress standpoint answer all of the
haters and the the detractors online and
the lovers and and the lovers there's
well there's well get to the XRP army
who as i in preparation was thinking you
must be the commander of the XRP army
I'm not sure that well I definitely
don't consider myself the commander's NZ
army I'm not sure there's a few people
who may be probably contend for that
position I'm not one of them all right
so let's start from the beginning you
actually have a life before ripple which
some people may not realize even in the
technology sector for a really long time
yahoo a lot all the older no experienced
are experienced one of my partner's is
mid-50s and I when we go through
everything I always say this is our
experienced partner let's talk about AOL
and Yahoo
kind of give us a quick overview what
you do at each one and we talk to some
of that experience I'll start with Yahoo
just cuz I think for me that was a
really formative experience in lots and
lots of ways I joined in early 2003 and
was there till I think the beginning of
2008 or 9 I can't remember which anyway
and it was a great experience partly cuz
that was you kind of joined or joining
in early 2003 there's kind of a dark
period for a lot of internet companies
and certainly I would put Yahoo on that
list and just both measured by stock
price but also just engagement and then
new leadership was coming in and you
know we went through it kind of a golden
time at Yahoo where a lot of growth and
it's hard for I think today's younger
generation to realize I mean Yahoo was
Google of 2003 right sure and that was
an awesome experience had some great
mentors professionally ran a whole bunch
of things at Yahoo ranging from the
homepage to
mail to Flickr and a handful of other
things and you've just learned a lot as
a leader and manager one of the
highlights / interesting experiences
there was I ended up becoming a little
bit infamous for something called a
peanut butter manifesto what is that the
Peter manifesto was a document I wrote
it was an internal document that I wrote
it did leak out after about 10 weeks but
the articulation was basically like
yahoo had a problem with spreading
itself too thin and I think this is true
not just at Yahoo but many companies
suffer from the almost an identity
crisis who are we what are we trying to
be and if you try to be all things to
all people you're not gonna be anything
to anybody and I think Yahoo is
struggling it like hey are we gonna be a
search company we're gonna be an email
company we may be a Content company in
news and sports and fantasy and there's
eventually manifestations of this but
the internal characterization we talked
about excuse me the internal
characterization as we talked about the
budgeting process and they senior person
referred to as well we spread around
like peanut butter and to me it was a
cringy moment where I'm like that is
exactly the problem you know if you want
to be great at something let's decide to
be great at that and then over invest in
that and potentially at the expense of
other things that maybe we have to
divest or exit or whatever but as the
internet grew holistically you had
specialization expertise and if we were
gonna compete with Google and search
which I know people probably hear that
and think how is that even possible
in 2003 that was really possible 2004
the the homepage I if I remember
correctly at Yahoo was like one of the
most visited if not the most visited web
page in the right yeah for a period of
time I don't I mean it was when I was
managing it and it was certainly a high
point to kind of you know thinking about
programming and a lot of interesting
stories about kind of you know things
that transpired in those eras but it was
a different time that it is for Yahoo
today for sure and so you go from Yahoo
AOL timeframe to you then become the CEO
of a technology startup and when I was
doing much of prep work as a father file
sharing startup right and so I'm
assuming that that kind of forays into
some stuff you're doing now but maybe
just tell us a little bit about what you
guys were doing there and
you know what drew you from the larger
kind of corporations to something I was
a little bit smaller and fast growing
well I I've always kind of viewed myself
more as a startup entrepreneurial guy
before Yahoo I had been CEO of a small
voice over IP company kind of early days
of VoIP this is pre pre Skype and so I
knew that going from Yahoo to an early
stage company was probably in the cards
you know anytime I'm thinking about a
career shift and might counsel to
anybody would be think about long-term
trends and I think one of those pretty
maybe overly obvious in 20 I think was
2011 what I was joining the company at
the time is called you send it we
rebranded to hightail but cloud-based
file management you know again now it's
like okay everybody's using that all the
time that was actually kind of new in
2011 and you said it had a pretty
extensive user base and the idea was
yeah and it was a bit of a turnaround
because you send it it kind of reached
its kind of high point if you will and
so how can we offer additional services
expand that and I think you know things
went reasonably okay there we continue
to grow it the challenge is when you've
got you know the Microsoft's of the
world and Google's of the world entering
the space with kind of either a loss
leader or for free and certainly having
Dropbox and box as competitors it was a
really tough slog and ultimately we're
not trying to sell the company it did it
did end up selling to a company called
Open Text but I exited and you know
decided to take some time off and look
at what's next got it
and so then you pop up again in the
crypto world right kind of after that
time off let's start with kind of what's
the first time you remember hearing
about crypto blockchain Bitcoin some
other you know application of technology
like do you remember what that was and
how to what caught our attention there's
a conference that's kind of under the
radar that gentleman Orrin Hoffman and
Peter Thiel organized each year called
dialogue dialogue and I attended I
attended a bunch times but in 2012 I
tended dialogue with number of friends
and there was a session on Bitcoin and
on the flight home sitting with some of
these guys who often are referred to you
know some of these guys are patient zero
for many of so
Bitcoin energy and by the time we landed
I was like okay okay okay I'll buy some
Bitcoin what year is this twenty twelve
twenty okay so real early and kind of
that nucleus of people who now most
people know are are excited about it
yeah and I mean you know this is with
Wednesday's guitarist mikki Malka good
friend of mine Dave Goldberg he passed
away but you know made friends with
those guys the the thing that I probably
was unconvinced of in that era was
what's the long-term opportunity of
Bitcoin in a world where it's fighting
against governments and fighting against
banks and fighting against the
institution the man now obviously that's
part of the genesis of Bitcoin but I was
always kind of it I you know you're I
often wonder okay if you took a slightly
different strategy with these things
would you reach broader adoption would
you impact more people more quickly and
when I had not heard of ripple I got a
recruiting call and you know we kind of
got ones really led to another so
basically you're kind of first furay was
Bitcoin and more of what I'll call like
the crypto ethos if you will and then
inbound recruiting call ended up kicking
off the process for ripple yeah it's
kind of amazing yeah it's kind of a
colorful story and you'll maybe find it
interesting yeah I had left hightail I
had time on my hands and so I decided
I'd be an uber driver I thought that
would be fun so I drove it over for
about a month and one day a recruiter
who I happened to know not super well
and knew him I remember partly because
he kept trying to call me and I kept
hitting ignore because I had a passenger
in the car anyway I finally spoke to him
and he says you know have you heard of
ripple and I lied and I said yes but
tell me what it does again anyway so he
describes what ripple is trying to do
and the kind of internet of value and
payments and the honest reaction I said
look super interesting I'm not your guy
I'll give you some names from PayPal or
Visa you know my sense is that's kind of
more up the alley what you're looking
for and in what he said which i think is
somewhat true is that chris larson is
one of the cofounders of red bull he's
like no he's really looking for someone
if you want to change an industry it's
easier to do it a little bit for the
outside perspective and if you hire
someone from the industry it's harder to
achieve that
outcome from the time that you got the
call till the day you quit driving an
uber how long was that well I I knew
that wasn't that long because I didn't
drive uber very one month project but
that was a fun experience and a whole
different for a different interview for
a different day
San Francisco is probably one of the
only you know Bay Area San Francisco's
probably the only areas for the people
who are driving for uber could have
previously had some crazy other life and
then in the future could next day be
running a technology company yeah there
are a couple funny moments I mean so one
I this is 2014 and I was an early Tesla
driver and so I was picking people up in
my Tesla as an uberx and a lot of people
at that time particular I'd never been
in a Tesla so you pick people up and
they've been kind of oh yeah holy [ __ ]
wait a minute and anyway a couple people
did figure out who I was and they would
tweet about it after the fact but the
you know his brother amusing that's
awesome
all right so let's dive into Ripple
first you joined in 2015 as the CEO as
CEO CEO oh okay what drew you to ripple
eventually kind of what was the the lore
if you will as to why to join this one
company out of all comes a Bay Area well
it's a good question I interviewed as a
bunch of different companies at the time
and I think you know for me given where
I was in my career I was less interested
in kind of how do I take a base hit or a
double it's kind of like look if you
want to do something I would really have
a opportunity to borrowing a Steve Jobs
ISM put a dent in the universe and
there's a whole lot of things in the
kind of whatever web 2.0 web 3.0
whatever we're in where I look at the
thing and I'm like wait this isn't that
I mean it's kind of like Oh could you as
a capitalist make money sure but yeah a
better marketplace for dog walkers I it
doesn't speak to me like it doesn't
speak to me is like you're changing and
impacting the world in a positive way
and I'm not taking anything away from
those that have a more efficient dog
walking experience dogs are happier the
dogs are happier and bother the dog
walkers way re you know there's more
money yeah I'm not I know I'm not trying
to be a hater towards that but when I
look at Garlin house is a dog walk hater
it was a rumor a triple for a while that
I hated dogs and you don't allowed to
have dogs at work on the side that's
wasn't true either but anyway so I as I
was looking you know I wanted to do
something I felt like this really if it
works could really have a big impact and
so my risk tolerance might have been
higher than some and you know I had been
talking to the team at Hoover about a
position there I'd been talking a couple
other things and I was drawn to ripple
in part because it felt like it was it
was a big swing meaning it was a chance
there's gonna be it wasn't going to work
and there's a chance like well wait a
minute actually if this works it could
be a really impactful in a lot of ways
and you know I think through a little
bit of luck a little bit skill you know
I think we find ourselves in a pretty
interesting spot ok so look that far
ahead so know well for those that don't
know there are at a high level two
separate components to what you guys are
doing there's ripple and there's XRP I
want to make sure that we separate those
and talk about each one individually
first so ripple when somebody says to
you what does ripple do how do you
respond and kind of describe the
business from your perspective well I
usually respond by I grew up actually in
the Midwest in Kansas and I explained to
people that when my mom asks me what I
do I say mom we sell software to banks
pretty simple pretty straightforward not
a lot of drama about that the fact that
the software were selling includes
components of blockchain technologies
includes solutions that leverage digital
assets she doesn't I'm at the end of the
day I'm not even sure customers cared I
think one of my critiques of the crypto
ecosystem and before the show we were
talking about this conference in
Montreal last weekend which we can talk
more about but you know I think there's
this echo chamber of people getting so
excited about the technology we lose
sight of what problem are we trying to
solve for what customer and how are we
going to do that and how do you go to
market with it and I think I think what
is missing in the crypto ecosystem is
really a customer fixation these are
profound technologies I think an impact
lots of industries and lots of ways but
you know when I sit in these conferences
sometimes I hear people talking about
and frankly kind of geeking out about
different technical things I think you
know okay that's interesting but if you
don't think about the problem you're
trying to solve and there's a kind of
Silicon Valley
statement of you know are you a
technology in search of a problem or a
problem in search of a technology I
think with ripple we were clear about
what problem and how we're going to
apply this technology one of the first
things I did when I joined ripple there
are a number of different projects going
on we had koteas which is a smart
contract platform we had something
called global identity which is intended
to be a and I leveraging a blockchain
leveraging XRP ledger for identity
management and there's this payments
solution and one of the hard decisions
early on you know back to that peanut
butter reference is we're a small
company we cannot pursue all three of
those things and be successful mm-hmm
let's pick one mm-hmm did we pick the
right one I don't know you know this is
pre etherium as the smart contracts
platform and vitalik and our CTO at the
time a guy named Stefan Thomas were
close and actually taluk was staying on
his couch and they were talking about
smart contracts platforms there's only a
couple hundred people at that point that
are into all this stuff right so they
all do a small community yeah anyway
yeah we decided to focus on you know
payments as a solution and liquidity as
a solution for financial institutions
and again I yeah you can never know is
that the right path but I think that
focus of going very narrow and very deep
has served us well I think there's a lot
of people in the industry who've gone
wide and thin where there's a lot of
experimentation but not a lot of
traction and clear demonstrable usage
for sure
so one caveat I should put out in the
conversation which I was somewhat clear
on on Twitter but I think it's important
for listeners to know I actually know
very little about ripple and XRP and so
I've got what I'll call a basic
understanding of what I could Google
around and learn about so I was excited
to do this because one I get to learn
from the source and then two is to try
to get a counter balanced view of the
world I reached out to a bunch of people
tweeted a bunch of times saying hey you
know send me all the questions similar
questions so I think I've got a much
more holistic view but my understanding
of what ripple is today in terms of
products and I want you to kind of gut
check me to make sure this is correct is
there's three separate products right
there's X current X rapid and X via are
the ones that kind of came up from all
the research online one is that an
accurate portrayal of kind of a
different
and then to Connie can you take us
through each product and what they do
exactly sure
so that is a reasonably fair
characterization you know they don't get
it perfect yeah well sort of that is you
know anytime you're in a sin industry it
changes quickly even ex rapid as a
product name we're kind of evolving to
something called on-demand liquidity
because that's kind of descriptive about
what it does but that's not that
critical for today so those are the
three products I'll talk briefly about
them X Current is really the idea that
banks today use existing pools of
liquidity so pre-funded accounts if I
have the bank of pump and the bank of
Brad you can be Mexican pesos all the US
dollars I would pre fund Mexican pesos
at your bank and you would pre fund
dollars my bank and then we'd use Swift
to debit and credit that with our first
product X current you can do that much
more efficiently much more quickly than
how the current system works and not
surprisingly banks like that that's good
and so we have had adoption of X current
but to be clear and I think one of the
things that there's misunderstanding
about years ago is that doesn't touch
crypto that is you know it kind of we
describe it as kind of a temporary
blockchain between two endpoints that's
a private transaction it's not going to
be published you know banks and
financial financial institutions have
sensitivity about the transactions being
broadcast everywhere but that's the
first product the second product X rapid
which we now really call on-demand
liquidity is this idea that I don't have
to pre-fund to the bank of pump I don't
want to put Mexican pesos out there I
don't really trust the bank of pump and
increasingly I don't want to have truly
there's trillions of dollars pre funded
and accounts around the world if I as a
bank don't have to pre-fund that
liquidity out into the world I can use
it for other purposes now there's a
whole bunch of things go with that you
know one is if I'm funding the Mexican
peso is reasonably stable but if I was
let's say the Argentinian peso there's a
lot of currencies out there you don't
want to hold and if you hold them you're
gonna try to hedge them on top of that
you have things like quarterly
compliance requirements about house the
bank of pump doing I've got you know
it's frankly one of these it changed
after the financial crisis there's
something called
forget a neighborhood talk my mind that
changed the regulatory framework of
Basel 3 is the Basel 3 changed the
regulatory requirement how banks tier 1
capital ratio is calculated it used to
be that the Bank of Brad could trust the
Bank of pump and the Bank of pump and
your regulators could trust the bank of
bread after the financial crisis we
realized we don't trust other banks so
my deposits that I have at the bank of
pump no longer count towards my capital
ratio so we talked about tier 1 capital
that no longer counts well guess what
that means the bank at pump in the mega
Bret I don't want to have those accounts
out there because it means I've got you
need more liquidity elsewhere and it's
because if I if I can bring those back
in rather than keep them at your bank
then they count towards my capital
that's correct or I can I can dip it in
that money I can do it or I want with
that money it's my money and and I don't
need to hold it on my end in order to
still use for transactions like I don't
just rather than hold it at your
institution I just now hold it up mine
for the transaction well that's what so
that's what this is what on-demand
liquidity solves and so with on-demand
liquidity or X rap it allows you to do
is say Bank a pump holds a dollar I'm
gonna sell the dollar I'm gonna buy a
unit of X RP I'm gonna move that unit of
x RP from a US dollar denominated
exchange to a Mexican peso to nominate
exchange I'm gonna sell the x RP I'm
gonna buy a Mexican peso you can have
that whole transaction completed in
seconds what today would mean
pre-funding and debit and crediting and
you know you're wiring in it if you're a
financial situation you might be sending
liquidity in every 10 days or something
now I can payment by payment or even its
Treasury
I can not pre fund 10 million dollars a
week I can send you know a hundred
thousand dollars every four hours and I
don't have to pre-fund so that that
allows me to bring working capital back
to me there's payment providers out
there some of these are public companies
so you know this isn't proprietary
information but MoneyGram has negative
working capital to the tune of hundreds
of millions of dollars of naked naked
working capital why because these pre
funded accounts got it if they don't
have the pre funded accounts all of a
sudden they have a lower I mean I'm not
pretending we're gonna solve this
overnight worldwide but over time if we
bring that from you know a few hundred
million to two hundred million to one
you know that the enterprise value of
money gram is some around 1.5 billion
debt plus the equity yeah if you could
move that by a couple hundred million
dollars that's actually really material
to a business like money grams now you
extrapolate that to not just other
remittance companies but banks it's a
very big deal for how global liquidity
is managed and the impact frankly to the
global economic engine we make global
commerce more efficient by making
payments more efficient if we can do
that at scale we can make the whole
economy more successful so one of the
question well let's go through X via
next and then we'll get into the x RP
income out of that work I'll keep X bi
super simple I think of it as a
corporate API wrapper so that a
corporate can write to one API and shoot
out payments globally okay and this is
all over one of the other terms that
kept coming up is ripple net correct is
that something separate than these three
products or those three products
represent ripple net so when you connect
into ripple net you're touching those
three products so if I am a bank can i
buy one product and not the other two or
do I get kind of all three wrapped up is
one one offering if you will from a
technical point of view I deploy it as
you're kind of getting all the pieces
that way if you signed up for X current
and you want to add on to X rapid later
or on-demand liquidity later it's an
easy evolution but you can sign up for
one product and a my as a bank you know
ripple comes to me salesperson or
customer person and says hey we've got
this product here's how it works here's
the advantages etc do you want to use it
I'm paying to use that product are you
taking a transaction fee is that an
upfront payment like how'd it just how
do I interact with ripple as a company
we have an enterprise sales force the
way I mean back to my kind of word
enterprise software company so we have
enterprise sales people out traveling
the world meeting with banks other
financial institutions and we're signing
contracts with them you know we've been
pretty traditional software contractor
yeah I mean traditional is lucy i mean
it's not salesforce you just light up an
instance this is not that right you're
deploying typically deploying behind the
firewall okay and so you know a
generically you know without disclosing
all how our contracts work you know your
site you're paying a software license
fee
typically paying a professional services
fee for deployment costs because again
we're typically sending people to your
location to do deployment work and the
third is transaction fees okay so kind
of like the first to sound similar like
an IBM type model right to give or take
you don't have to say IBM but somebody
like IBM software and then there's a
basically some sort of revenue you guys
derive from how much is used or the
transaction volume is somebody
participates in right got it okay so you
described earlier that some of the
products use XRP let's switch gears from
ripple to XR P now what is XR p and i
think this is where a lot of the
controversy lays probably so that let's
be really kind of thorough in terms of
how you would describe it and kind of
with the purposes XR P is an open source
software except utilizes open source
software the X XR p is the digital asset
resident on the XR p ledger some of the
founders of ripple were involved with
the creation of the XR p ledger the XR p
ledger started before ripple the company
was created all makes what explain this
so some of the people from ripple
involved in the creation but XR p ledger
was actually started before the company
ripple
so the sequentially a group of engineers
gets together and you know candidly some
of these engineers had been early
bitcoin engineers their view was hey
there's gonna be some scalability
limitations of how Bitcoin works they
set out to build a better Bitcoin I
think you know an impressively prescient
way they saw look if you extrapolate
this out and you really want this to be
the future of payments can you scale a
proof-of-work like model to be to enable
an internet of value and that's that's
challenging so they were like and I
think they would attest to their
original view was hey we're gonna set
out to build a better Bitcoin we're
gonna build Bitcoin 2.0 and you know we
don't talk about that today because I
don't view this as a competition between
Bitcoin and XRP I don't you I mean I
think there's gonna be multiple winners
in this the internet will take care of
that competition yeah they definitely
the marketplace will take care of the
competition meaning it you know it's not
going to be the chatter of
the echo-chamber of Twitter and the
crypto world it's gonna be customers you
know is this solving a problem for
customers I just point out look I think
one of the areas of FUD is people are
like Brad hates Bitcoin I am long
Bitcoin I own Bitcoin I am not bearish
on Bitcoin I just don't bitcoin is not
going to solve a payments problem
so the Satoshi white paper says a
payments network it's not going to be a
payments network and the reason is that
the nature of proof of work and if from
a scalability point of view is
significantly limiting how you know the
throughput transaction time transaction
cost the XRP ledger is much much much
more efficient I say it's about a
thousand times faster per transaction
it's about a thousand times cheaper per
transaction so one of the questions and
we're kind of jumping around a little
bit here so if you're listening bear
with us one of the things I think that
bit corners would say is there's a
relationship between security and speed
and if you speed up the transactions
then you could be giving up security
right in some there's some level of
trade-off there agree disagree do you
think that there's a kind of a more gray
areas not so black and white and just
how do you think of you know the
trade-off between speed security Bitcoin
and how XRP works I'm gonna
intentionally somewhat dodge the
question okay I'm like I've read that
meme and it's kind of a recent meme in
my opinion I didn't hear that two years
ago and now I've kind of read stuff now
people say that the XRP ledger has
existed since 2012
I think 2012 we've never had a
transaction on wound we've never had a
hack against the the ledger like so do I
think we have compromised do I think the
creators of the acceptor ledger
compromised security to the benefit of
efficiency and speed I don't see it I
think I'd like to see the data that I
mean a guy I've read that I've read that
meme and I but I've never read it and
you know here's an example of where
there's a people optimized for speed and
efficiency but then there is a security
issue mmhmm yeah and and I think it's a
fair point for you to say hey look this
has never been hacked
I mean generalize
I think that there's probably other
people who have tried to increase
efficiency therefore giving up some
security and there has been a hack and
so maybe a fair critique of that would
be if it happens one place doesn't me
it's gonna happen everywhere and also
what level of security is needed right
in order to run a system and if there is
a relationship between security and
speed is there some middle ground
between the two right yeah I guess I'm
just I'm challenging the premise that
there's a trade-off yeah better speed
III me buddy I'll be totally candid the
parties I'm dodging the question is like
I am NOT the cryptographer at Ripple
who's gonna wear the same boat so you
know I'm a little over my skis and
trying to defend this point but I I
think I'm reasonably smart about this
stuff I have read the meme that you're
trading off security for efficiency
mm-hmm I haven't seen any proof of that
the people who I trust the most from a
technology point of view in this area I
think if they were on your show would
argue that yeah I did enough to do that
the Twitter detectives go to work go
argue about that you can tweet at me
about how wrong sweet Joel cats on that
also and he'll defend me that is fair
all right so XRP is a digital asset that
goes on the XRP ledger right and then
describe kind of how it works into the
product itself because it sounds like
it's not all three products within the
ripple net actually use XRP some of them
do some of them don't so just kind of
with it the only product that we are
selling to customers that uses the XRP
ledger is on-demand liquidity okay right
so I was describing the Bank of pump
selling a camera if you were dollar peso
but you're selling whatever that Fiat is
you're buying XRP you're moving it
you're transacting back if you're just
going point to point on Fiat you're not
touching XRP mm-hmm and so some of the
pieces here I think are one banks do
this with Fiat it's slow there's a bunch
of issues there's the deposit issue that
stuff to is then somebody would say well
why don't you just use Bitcoin or some
other digital asset instead of X or P it
is a great question if I know I'm in a
rut if I may we had a really interesting
debate internally when we were
architecting and
product design around X rapid or
on-demand liquidity and one of the
debates internally was a wait a minute
what happens if we're launching
on-demand liquidity into Poland and
there is I think it's one maybe let's
not use that we think that's the euro
let's do that Peru I think it's the lira
you know three honestly I my skis on
that too if we're going into a market
where there's no liquidity with XRP then
our product isn't going to work mm-hmm
so we architected the product to be
flexible enough to say look maybe eath
has a ton of liquidity into peru maybe a
Bitcoin has a ton of liquidity into Peru
the the point here is we were focused on
solving the customers problem if that
meant that we were using Bitcoin to
solve it okay so we made the product
flexible enough that it would use the
most efficient rail now it happens to be
that we have never used anything other
than XRP because actually XRP is
extremely fast and extremely inexpensive
on a per transaction basis do you look
at it as X RP is the default and then if
there's not the liquid II then you would
go to the other ones right yeah I think
it's right about yeah got it okay by the
way the reason I'm emphasizing that is
back to you even I can't member what you
said earlier but you're talking about
what I heard was kind of this there is
religions around all things crypto
tribalism absolute rival ism religiosity
whatever you know yeah and I think it's
really unhealthy okay
I I just had somebody on who said that
toxicity was positive so go ahead go
yeah III don't I don't know who that was
but I look and I got this I mean I
thought this conference I was at in
Montreal is just be super confidential I
saw an article about a moderate
consensus so apparently it's not that
confidential but more things I argued in
front of this kind of hundred people is
I don't think what ripple is doing is
competing with almost anybody else in
that room at that point and I'm sure
they're examples of people who are
competing with but I want them to be
successful mm-hmm I want the eath
projects to be successful I want the
Bitcoin projects to be successful I
don't view that as a bad thing for us in
fact the more successful they are the
better it is for me in fact when I hear
about companies in our space that are
struggling and might have a bad outcome
and that's bad for me mm-hmm I think
we're at a stage and you know I I joined
the internet space we didn't get back to
my early early time but I moved to
Silicon Valley in 1997
this is you know a year ish past the
Netscape IPO it was early days and I
feel very similar like look all boats
can rise here and I when I hear about
the tribalism about the toxicity I'm not
here to hate on almost anybody but I I'm
here to hate on people who aren't
open-minded and thoughtful and are you
know maybe almost pedantic in their
approaches just like this is better
because I want to solve a customer
problem using a set of technologies that
includes the XRP ledger that includes
the digital asset XRP I think we're
doing that effectively we're scaling
very quickly it's going well I would
think other people would want to root
for that success because I think we're
the only scaled scaled blockchain crypto
solution out there . . there's a lot of
experiments you think that you're the
only skilled Satyan i think that what
ripple is doing is the only scaled
example of crypto and blockchain being
used like at scale period let me qualify
that because i'm gonna go berserk on
that i just tried to save you for the
record how do you measure that
well i mean is it okay so first of all
i'll back off at by saying look clearly
bitcoin is a store of value as a use
case i believe in i'm long bitcoin that
that is working it's it is scaled what
i'm talking about more is that
enterprise solution there's a lot of
experiments around how block chains can
impact different kinds of transactions I
use the word experiments really
specifically I can't point to other
examples where I mean ripple has
hundreds of customers using these
technologies to solve a real problem we
have real volume you know we can get
into some of that volume information but
like things are going really really well
I want these other projects do really
really well
so let's get into progress because
that's a huge question people have just
and I think this is coming both from the
the believers and the detractors camp of
just like where are you guys today so
hundreds of customers
my understanding is some big names some
small names everyone in between what
kind of data can you share in terms of
you know kind of milestones or
data that illuminates what that progress
has been right so a whole bunch of
thoughts I'll throw in here one is so we
have publicly disclosed we have over two
hundred customers I don't think we've
updated the number since then you know
we have you can update right now I don't
think I know the exact number at some
point I I'm not trying to be
tongue-in-cheek but like you stop
counting at some point it's just like
are we at 248 or 260 I don't know yeah
what I have also publicly shared is that
we have been on a pace of signing about
two to enterprise-grade contracts per
week okay so what that basically means
is you have 52 weeks in a year we're
signing on average about a hundred
contracts I will sign more than that
this year we beat our forecast for q3
that just ended last week and you know
that's a leading indicator of increased
adoption let's say one interesting kind
of anecdote we were at Sipos big banking
conference in London a few weeks ago and
meeting with a bank we don't work with
today big transaction Bank
correspondent bank and the team they
were sitting down and that one of the
guys are him said well it's become a
question of not if we're gonna work with
ripple its when because 26 of their
correspondents are already working with
ripple got it so if you're this Bank and
you're not working with ripple it
actually is inefficient for them not to
actually join the network and this is
one of the reasons why I get excited
about the business model the network
effects you know there's Metcalfe's law
the value of the network expands based
on a square of the nodes on the network
mm-hmm
we're seeing that happen you know that
the thing that that the sceptics should
ask is well if you were the first five
customers to sign up for ripple net why
would you sign up it's like the first
person bought a telephone there's nobody
talked to which is true I tell my Sales
Lead that his job gets easier day by day
and like there's evidence to show that
it does now translating that traction
with a customer contract and one of the
first okay ours which is how we kind of
managed objectives aqui we're using
silicon valley lanes all right you get
them all a mess okay ours are basically
like key performance metrics perfect
when I first got to the company our key
performance metric was contracts and
over time I realized that the contracts
wasn't the most important metric
it was deployments because you can sign
the contract but if it's not deployed
within some reason a lot of time you
have made much progress then we started
tracking deployments as the most
important metric and then we realized
it's actually not deployments is
actually volume because at some point
you want to sell the contract deploy it
and then you want volume going over
either in a new use case being built on
a new rail or moving an existing volume
over to that rail so today are the key
metric we track more than any else's
volume I'm gonna track primarily volume
by trend number of transactions as
opposed to dollar volume okay and the
reason is like to some degree you could
do a small number we have a handful of
customers that it's you know corporate
use cases where there's one large Bank
where their average transaction size is
tens of millions of dollars per
transaction
that kind of skews all the other data
because you have other transactions like
$30 each ultimately we think about the
number of transactions the number of
transactions has been doubling quarter
over quarter for about eight quarters
okay well you give us a ballpark of
where I don't know I honestly don't know
many thousands we're not yet I there's a
chance we'll hit millions this year
millions per quarter or millions per
year so chance will hit there's a chance
we'll hit millions this year so millions
in one single 12-month period yeah I
know I mean there's a couple things on
the wire we're kind of protective about
what we disclose one is these are banks
institutions like I don't have
permission to share you know that they
get rather sensitive when I start
sharing specifics about their
transaction Bank it's it's competent so
I should do that I will I'll let you off
the hook to a degree with one question
that I saw from Twitter and I forget who
asked it so I apologize but you get
credit is my credit to the Twitter user
is they said what percentage of the
customers race they basically saying
look I believe that you sign up all
these customers right it's very obvious
that if you have a better software
product to give to them and can help
them run their business doe they're
gonna pay for it it's just classic
business but what percentage of the
customers have more than one percent of
all their volume go through a ripple net
type engagement or product versus that's
a neighbor say going else what mother I
think that's a good and interesting
question I don't see it
presumes that I know their total volume
that's fair which I would imagine
typically we don't know okay now I mean
there are some customers where I mean
let's let's use MoneyGram as an example
that's very public that they're working
with us and what-have-you
right now we're only live in you know
two corridors okay Mexican peso and
Philippine peso okay so my get I'm
purely just conjecture here and they're
they're a public company so somebody
could probably figure this out but even
if we had a hundred percent of their
volume live and the Mexican peso in
Philippine peso what percentage of the
total would that be I don't know I'm not
my guess is those two quarter of Mexico
is probably very very big percentage of
business meeting well but big meeting
maybe twenty at most maybe ten no no
what do you think let's just take that
as an example what do you think your
volume in Mexican peso is in terms of
compared to them using ripple net versus
not 50/50 it's less than that now in
ramping and the reason why that's the
case is we are slowly increasing one of
the key things we talked about earlier
is you need liquidity between X R P and
M X in so one of the challenges thanks
for the whole crypto world is I've been
fond of saying that the long-term value
of any digital asset will be derived
from the utility it delivers the utility
for most crypto today is purely
speculation now we could argue that
that's a step forward from your illicit
use cases of Silk Road and so we've gone
from illicit use cases to speculation I
think the next chapter will be all about
real utility but if today 99.9% of
speculation I have said you know look we
want to get all crypto from 99.9 to 99
298 to 97 what have you there have been
days over the last handful of weeks
where eighty percent of the volume to XR
p and m xn was associated with our and
of on-demand liquidity product so we
went from 99.9 to 20 being speculation
now that actually creates a different
problem the problem that creates is if
there's not enough liquidity can we push
more value through that pipe unless
there's more liquidity and so we work
with market makers and to some degrees
liquidity begets liquidity if there's a
market there
market makers whether you know in all
shapes and sizes will participate and
hoping to kind of generate their own
value from participating there for sure
and so last question around kind of just
progress as you're signing let's say two
contracts per week on average right
you're kind of doubling the transactions
quarter-over-quarter
things appear you know based on that
data kind of being up into the right
where are you finding a bank that is
kind of the average customer what is the
value to them right in terms of you've
got these three products are they coming
in and saying hey I'm actually using all
three of these as part of ripple net and
I kind of get the full experience do you
find that they're just using one of the
three more than the others like what is
the I guess kind of a value proposition
that the average customer is finding
today I'd say 90% of the customers first
touch point is Forex current okay
because it's solving a problem that they
it's it's easy to kind of explain the
value proposition you already have two
pools liquidity you're using some sort
of solutions who settle between those
two her messaging this is a better way
to do that and that's the entry point
once we are at the entry point then we
can say to the bank at pump hey you have
you know you have a correspondent in the
Philippines your the costs to maintain
that correspondent is whatever hey
there's a better way to do that let's
find a more efficient way to do that and
you know oftentimes you know people
first hear the word crypto there's a
little bit of a particularly the banking
world once you explain to someone that
every ripple enabled transaction is KY
seed every ripple naval transaction is
checked for AML oh fak you know other
acronyms filled in all of a sudden like
oh okay this is just this is better
there's a better way to facilitate
liquidity mm-hmm I think that the
posture for banks changes pretty quickly
if you don't mind I'll tell you one
anecdote on this it's kind of funny
about two and a half years ago a very
senior guy from a big correspondent bank
with whom we were working says hey Brad
you know look we're super excited be
working with you just want you to know
that this whole like they were using X
current and you know he took it upon
himself to say look that we love what
we're doing but just so you know like
we're never gonna use crypto for
liquidity okay I get you thank you you
know
we're thrilled to be working with you
happy place 18 months later same guy and
the CEO of the entire Bank come to visit
our office in San Francisco and what
they said is hey we're ready to start
talking about how you can help us with
liquidity what was interesting to me
about that is you know we had the
opportunity to talk to him about how
they can use XRP for liquidity because
we're already a trusted partner and
solving a problem for them and how they
already worked and I think that we keep
kind of breaking down those walls and I
think that's good for the whole crypto
community by the way dispelling the idea
that crypto is inherently somehow you
know used for illicit purposes and those
things you know I think it's talking
about real use cases solving real
problems having real utility I think is
good for the whole industry so this is a
great Segway because another set of
questions and this came from a whole
different group of people and I kind of
distilled them down into a couple of
bullet points was one of the big things
that I think Bitcoin specifically gets
both praise and detraction about is its
lack of ability for law enforcement or
governments to stop it right so there's
a lot of people who love the fact that
hey you can't censor this stuff you
can't seize it you know all the other
things that we you know believe it that
Bitcoin reach the table the flip side of
that is there's a lot of people who
don't like that right hey there's
dynamic sanctions and government's don't
like that oh it's not a lot of people
don't like that governments don't like
that there's funny people right
and so there's a whole set of questions
I kind of just put this under like law
enforcement and governments and so
things like you know how does Ripple
deal with government requests about user
information or account blacklisting and
the things that I think people say
that's not possible when it comes to
Bitcoin how do you guys handle that have
you guys had those requests maybe just
kind of elaborate on some of those
issues
skirts want to know who has the best URL
crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want
krypter calm go help your boy out tell
them pomp sent you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy comps
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do is control it from
the mobile app they provide and then you
receive over-the-air updates that add
new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com
tell them pom sent you and thank me
later one more word from our sponsor
blocked by their new interest account
allows you to securely deposit your
Bitcoin or Ethernet block by and receive
6% annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent ap
Y which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pop again block 5 comm slash
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today
how does ripple deal with government
requests about user information or
account blacklisting and the things that
I think people say that's not possible
when it comes to Bitcoin how do you guys
handle that have you guys had those
requests and we just kind of elaborate
on some of those issues well I'll start
with the rather simplistic answer we
don't write we don't
on board customers mm-hmm the bank of
pump does okay if the government wants
to come and look at a transaction for
the bank of Pop they go to make a pump
that nothing changed so I mean I'm being
a little bit overly simplistic but the
way that the bank of pop is regulated
today whether they're using ripples
Technologies underneath or not mm-hmm
doesn't change
okay so in the when they want to come
and about this is for ripple yep if they
want to come and validate a make it more
exact example you were yep so let's say
that I want to I'll give you two
examples let's say that I'm a person of
interest to the government and I send a
transaction to somebody
it goes through ripple net x RP she goes
through a bank a regulated financial
institution and might another regulated
financial institutions yep and the
government says I want to learn more
about that they go to the bank and I'm
assuming that they send you guys
requests as well or no I mean we we
don't necessarily have the ident you
know back to the privacy of you know we
sign a customer we don't necessarily
have that information but a matter of
fact not just we don't necessarily I'm
trying to think an example where we
would have that information the bank of
pumps transacted the Bank of Brad I you
know I don't get the identity cuz I
didn't do an onboarding so basically the
way and this is me learning here for a
second there's two ways that these
systems work right is there could be I
don't want to call it shielded because I
think that has a negative connotation
but basically this idea that Bank of pop
sends money to Bank of Brad the
processor of that transaction can see
personally identify them identify what
information it can see all the details
the transaction who it is all that kind
of stuff and then there's a way for it
to basically happen without any sort of
information being shared from the bank
to the payment processor which bucket
are you guys in the ladder the ladder
okay I mean but both endpoints that the
bank of property maybe I shouldn't say
the bank of Brad because I am Ripple but
you know both endpoints see the
information and they have access to
information and we actually one of the
things that we do through ripple net is
make the passing of that information
much more robust than how Swift works
today the banks like that and frankly
governments like that yeah you know this
idea that I independent my own political
views this idea that crypto is gonna
kind of take down governments but might
be for certain segments appealing I
think about this a little more
pragmatically how do we apply these
technologies to bring greater efficiency
to commerce to greater efficiency for
the immigrant who lives in you know San
Jose California and wants to send money
home to Guatemala and 30% of their
transaction is coming out in fees like
that's shitty you know that doesn't need
to be that way you're basically saying
like many companies in crypto for sure
hey there's rules there's regulations
we're gonna play within the rules and
regulations yeah right but the only
thing you said there that didn't
necessarily grow things like many in
crypto yeah I think one of the
challenges is a lot of people in crypto
I think are doing a disservice by you
know championing things that we know
that governments aren't gonna be on
board with yeah and part of it too is
right it's always a balance between
somebody's got to break the rules to
change the rules but at the same time if
you break the wrong rules or you do the
wrong things then there's punishments
right and so it's kind of I've got you
ready for this I got a saying that one
of my partner says all time he goes
pioneers end up in ditches well look I
also think there's a difference between
you know I can on a personal level I can
look at what uber was doing and kind of
disrupting the taxi Union and think okay
like I get it you know you start talking
about the disruption of let's say you're
the intentional circumvention of kyc
require requirements you know I know
there are examples and you know with
governments that maybe aren't to be
trusted and you could argue maybe the US
government to be trusted we live in a
world of governments that's not gonna
change anytime soon
we do a kind of an annual customer
conference called swell and a couple
years ago actually exactly two years ago
we did in Toronto and Ben Bernanke was
our keynote and I thought he you know
but first of all I was great back to
that gets good for the crypto community
Ben Bernake he's doing a keynote for a
crypto conference in effect I mean
obviously ripples a little did also and
Snoop Dogg once right that was for he
wasn't speaking at a conference with us
that's another story let's talk about
that I'm just impressed you got Ben
Bernanke and Snoop Dogg that's nice X
months apart keep going all right so
what Ben Bernanke was saying which I I
subscribe to is that if you're talking
about g20 markets to give up the ability
for them to control their money supply
is giving up their sovereignty they're
gonna bring out the tanks before they
give up their sovereignty his point was
basically that you know if what you are
doing is threatening to threatening the
sovereignty of a nation that is a that
is a very high kind of attack on a
nation and they're gonna fight that
aggressively and so I when I see people
doing things in the crypto world that I
feel like I use g20 specifically because
look there are many countries have
already lost control their money supply
you know we could choose them Bob way as
a example that is amusing to learn about
but there's a whole lot of markets you
know when I use the g20 that they're not
gonna just sit idly by and you know have
their Fiat and have their ability to
control monetary policy be disrupted for
sure one more question on this and we'll
move on if I am Bank of Pop and since we
won't use Bank of Broadway well for a
laughs in' and jokes
we'll call Bank of Satoshi that I'm
gonna send said money - very good if I
think there would be a banker Satoshi by
now there probably is so somebody so
much guided they somebody definitely
bought the domain Bank of Satoshi calm
you're welcome for the free advertising
uh-huh if I send money from Bank of pomp
to Bank of Satoshi but Bank of Satoshi
is located in Iran let's say right so a
company that are a country that is
sanctioned by the US massive
ramifications if you tried to do this in
the church you know quote unquote
traditional banking system one can I do
that through riffle net I'm assuming no
but I'll let you clarify and then -
along with that can you as ripple or
ripple net blacklist certain accounts
etc or is that done at a bank level what
is your control over in terms of
blacklisting and preventing write
sending of money in reverse order we
can't blacklist because we don't have
PII
okay so percent identify if I could
blacklist pump I would this is a general
rule not pump but there some others out
there that I might we could on the first
question we don't work with any banks in
Iran you know when we think about what
quality is the first of all there's
obviously US government requirements
about certain
into business with Iran would be on that
list when we think beyond that you know
if if a bank is a swift enabled Bank we
generally look at that and say okay
they're part of the global banking
infrastructure
ergo there's no reason why ripple
shouldn't work with them yeah I think
the question is less about the specific
country more so whatever the rules of a
legacy bank are presented right so if
they can't send money to Iran XRP can't
be sent there as well through ripple net
because you're working with these
banking partners yeah they get your mind
that the bank of pump by the end of the
day you you Bank a pump can be connected
to ripple net and you still are choosing
with whom you're settling across the
network so I mean if let's not use Iran
let's use let's use in Bob way cuz I'm a
lot of people might have concerns about
settling banks in Zimbabwe yeah I think
you may choose I'm not I'm even though
I'm connected ripple net even though
it's super efficient it's super fast
super low-cost do I want to have as a
correspondent a bank in Zimbabwe yeah
that that's up to you up to me yeah got
it all right so I want to play a game
but I call devil's advocate but before
we play and the point of this game is
essentially to present to you the eye
kiss eight thousands hundreds of people
or tens of people who tweeted at me all
kinds of crazy conspiracy theories
detractions
and then even some that seemed pretty
valid right in terms of what they were
saying before we do that though the
number one topic by far that everyone
was focused on was XRP sales right yeah
there's a whole bunch of stuff around
that before I say any questions you just
kind of describe how do the sales work
and kind of as you sit on the ripple
side of CEO how do you view XRP escrow
sales revenue all this guy yeah alright
so I'll start talking about I'm sure I'm
gonna miss a couple things you just
asked about there because there are a
whole bunch of good questions in there
it's a great interview technique to
throw out a bunch of questions and they
just so I mean look I'm glad you're
asking about this I think there's a
bunch of misinformation you know before
the show I said to you look one of the
reasons I'm here is because I think
there's a bunch of misinformation and I
think we need to get a little more
aggressive about clarifying some of that
the first thing I'll say that people
kind of lose sight of I think is we are
the most interested party in the success
and health of the XRP ecosystem we being
ripple we ripple we don't I mean it's
very transparent we own a lot of XRP
anything we do that's not good for the
XRP ecosystem is not good for I mean
above it there's a whole bunch of other
players in the XRP ecosystem some of
their companies we've invested in some
are doing their own upended thing just
this week a bunch of announcements about
SDK this is a an announcement or this
week around SDKs around XMP ledger that
I think are profound and all I see more
people building on top of the XRP ledger
that's good for the whole the whole
group when we think about what we're
doing
we've tried one to be very transparent
in the kind of context of leading by
example I think one of the limitations
that the crypto ecosystem broadly faces
is lack of transparency if we're not
going to be transparent we shouldn't
expect people to you know trust us now
in some ways I admit in a frustrating
way our transparency has opened us up to
attack okay so hold on a pause for a
second pause the one thing that I will
say is I do believe that your life would
be easier if you didn't provide any
information because P sadly I agree
because people would what I what I
honestly believe and this is across
every single company public companies
specifically right pump public companies
would have less scrutiny in many cases
if they were private right same thing
kind of applies here is the more
information you put out whether you're
right or wrong whether you're fully
transparent or semi-transparent people
then now have data points right right
and they can use that to all that stuff
right yeah example of this I'll point to
I got Joe Lubin and I were on a panel in
Davos the earlier this year okay and Joe
Rubin was criticizing I can't remember
exactly if there's a video of it
somewhere out on the internet but he's
criticizing you know ripple and XRP and
you know we and Isaac we're on the panel
with them yeah well I actually like
that's pretty ballsy he was being direct
you know I don't I think it kind of
backfired on him you can go watch the
video you make your own judgment but I'm
like okay wait a minute we're gonna
criticize what ripples doing how much
how much eath does Joe Lubin own how
much eat this consensus owned how much
are you selling what are you using that
for it you don't look I
I think the best way to lead is by
example and so ripple is tried to lead
by example
okay talk about the mechanism of escrow
sales kind of how the whole process work
so just don't worry about numbers right
now yeah I'm gonna try to remember the
exact time for about two years ago one
of the big you know kind of overhangs if
you will concerns about the XRP market
had been ripple owns a lot of it what
happens if ripple decides to sell a lot
of it I always use the argument well
that wouldn't be in ripples best
interest why would we do that and the
concern there is basically if you dump
it all on the market all at once it
would depress the price that that's
that's one of the concerns I think
there's some others but yes and I of
course would always you know I always
says a little bit of just a silly
argument because that would not be in
our best interests why would we ever do
that we we took that off the table as a
concern by saying look I'll tell you
what we are gonna lock up in so the XR p
ledger has a capability called an escrow
can be cryptographically signed sealed
if you will and we created 55 contracts
55 escrows that effectively become
unlocked once a month for 55 months
there's 1 billion XRP in each escrow so
in month 1 so 55 billion XRP went into
asked up in in an escrow well in 55
escrows yep and then each one kind of on
a one by month basis each one kind of
fires off and releases 1 billion XRP
correct when it releases where does it
go we can do it everyone with it okay we
being a ripple okay these escrow you
know ripple owns the XRP yep we on our
own ignore some of the escrow so because
it one of the things that I don't think
I understood well and people are asking
questions so I apologize to anyone at
least I get this wrong is there like
it's not real escrow because ripple
still owns it what you're basically
saying is it's a quickly graphically
sign we can't unlock it yeah yeah so
it's I guess somebody couldn't get remit
you quote quote own it but there's
cryptographic signage on it yeah you
don't you can't catch that lady correct
right that's correct
okay so we go in and you get the billion
x RP e once a month for 55 we use some
of it for deals well back to you asked
we sell some programmatically
I want to talk ress on that for you
asked about earlier I didn't
we sell xrp two different ways okay
one is OTC over-the-counter okay
institutions come to us they want
exposure to xrp rather than going into
the market sometimes they'll come to us
and will facilitate a facilitated
transaction what okay let's go real slow
there because this is where all the
questions were what are the types of
institutions that come for OTC are these
like hedge foot crypto hedge funds or
these large Bank customer types more the
former than the latter
more than okay so this is more this is
where crypto speculators okay are coming
to you and saying hey we'd like to buy
over-the-counter correct gosh so now do
two things about two over-the-counter
piece one is you know so over the
history of the time I've been a company
out an order of magnitude would have
twenty to thirty unique players come to
us to buy XRP no that's really not that
many I thought it was gonna be way
higher than that no okay yeah I we
basically have stopped all OTC in large
part because our attitude is look
there's enough liquidity out in the
market you can go into the market and
get it market being you can go on an
exchange where you could go to other OTC
peri successful OTC desks and we refer
people to those OTC desks or yeah I
could go ahead and you know buy it on an
exchange I'm depends on the size but so
you know we back to our transparency we
put out what's called the XRP market
report okay once a quarter at the end of
each quarter we will publish exactly you
know hey this is how much XRP came out
this is how much XRP went in this is how
much we sold we sold some
programmatically with some sold OTC you
know last quarter was a high-water mark
in terms of the dollar value of XRP sold
okay and one of things that we actually
agree with is we tried to have a
constructive way to engage the market by
saying we're gonna sell OTC and we're
gonna sell programmatically at ten basis
points of daily market activity okay so
and that's a combined OTC in
programmatic or attendance points each
end basis points well the OTC tends to
be a little bit you know lumpy lumpy yes
okay thank you think that's helpful the
the ten basis points is much easier the
challenge of the ten basis points became
that we were using coin market cap as
the measurement stick
oops you know I use now [ __ ] we are
crypto compare top tier CCT T okay and
we think that's a much more trusted they
have an interesting construct around I'm
gonna get this slightly wrong what kind
of tier a tier B or tier with the entire
quality it's a higher court trustworthy
measure of actual volume in X RP
liquidity okay so let me ask one
question real quick is more personal
curiosity ten basis points of daily
market volume or of market volume is
that daily monthly okay so basically
every day would it be fair to say you
guys are ten basis points of the volume
give or take depending on dilution etc
yeah yeah I think that's right
I said 1% let's just say that there's a
hundred million dollars worth of daily
volume before you guys do anything right
there was we would be a hundred thousand
dollars yeah you don't suppose every day
for 99.9% of all XRP trading we have
nothing to do with got it okay we have
based upon what we saw a coin market cap
we've continued to kind of constrain
what we're doing in part because I think
people very appropriately are pointing
out like hey coin market cap isn't right
here at the right measure you know it's
coin market cap going to back to the
transparency and like I would challenge
them to challenge themselves like it's
bad for the whole market that that's not
a more trusted source so okay so
programmatically let's say the last
couple quarters how much do you think
you've sold and again one caveat this
whole conversation right I think a lot
of people want me to like hold your feet
to the fire and say like oh you said 100
million dollars but it was a hundred and
two yeah here's the good news just
ballpark there's a public number out
there that we have published for every
quarter of last eight to ten course the
ballpark in terms of diaphragmatic q1
well no III don't know if I can parse
programatic from OTC top and then I
think q1 both combined is about 170
million USD okay and q2 is about 250
million USD okay q3 is gonna be
dramatically lower okay we will put that
xfe market report out in a couple a week
or two okay so weeks a couple more
questions here
and again I caveat notice with this is
where all the questions are one what are
you doing with the money so basically
there's let's call q1 there's three
billion
xrp right that get unlocked over a
three-month period yeah
usually in the markets report by the way
we would have said I don't know top of
mind but three billion came unlocked and
this is how much went back into the 56
57 58 contract or escrows got it so you
say we don't contribute some of it back
to the another escrow not just some of
it but most of it I mean I would you
know order back to 80% of it goats back
goes back in okay you then sell 170
million q1 to 50 round numbers for q2 I
think one of the what we're getting into
the devil's advocate game now one of
them is what do you guys need all the
money for well I mean one we're
investing in both the company we're
investing in the you know money Graham
is an interesting deal we as I think is
very widely known we committed 50
million dollars to invest in money
Graham I think that has been a very
successful partnership and investment
for them and for us
they're super happy about it we're happy
about it and again I think these the
more we're doing to demonstrate scaled
use cases of solving real problems I
think that's good for everybody and how
much of the unlock one of the other
questions was around how much of the
unlock goes to the company versus what
they called company affiliates and that
was founders foundations kind of all
this other stuff well what we're talking
about right now is only what the company
owns okay so the only ripple the billion
gets released and you use some of it for
selling revenue right that you can then
go invest and do all that stuff with and
then some of it just gets contributed
back into future that's blocked escrows
correct okay one of the other big ones
was misleading market cap right and so
the big question here was and I'm
literally gonna read to you almost
verbatim good just to make sure I don't
screw it up
the last thing I want is to ask you
tough questions and then have get me get
yelled at by the internet here's the
good news I actually want you to ask too
because I honestly think there like most
the tough questions I think there's like
look I'm not an irrational human being
alright so long do I have to I do have
to say this on the record so everyone
can hear it we've never met before we
never talked before somebody asked me
the other day what I thought about this
I said I look I never the guy before we
got some mutual friends
they speak highly of you and I said I'll
tell you what the guy's got balls to
come in here like has no clue and I'm
about asked him so I'll give him that
I'm glad you say it because I think some
people like oh well you know he has to
pre-approve questions I think what I
said to you before we started as like
look anything's fair game yeah all right
I will even go further as to say the
folks that know that I was talking to
some of the people that ripple about
doing this that was gonna be one of my
where they call it like stopping points
is if they said hey I gotta see the
questions first
I wouldn't done it yes so misleading
market cap currently stated market cap
counts all distributed tokens including
those sent to founders affiliated
foundations and customers most of those
though are held with restricted selling
agreements so they're not actually
liquid if which can lead to an oversight
of market cap if the market cap did not
include those than the implied inflation
rate would be much higher therefore it
would be a better signal for the
downward selling pressure on XRP super
complicated question parse it a little
one quick sentence basically if you look
at the data the way that some of this is
calculated can be in the detractors eyes
misleading therefore people can't run
kirk models to understand the inflation
rate look I get the question actually at
a high level the my my response is
largely how do you calculation rate of
Bitcoin what about the whales who bought
Bitcoin in you know in year one and
they're selling some now do we count
that inflation rate mm-hmm
we don't but isn't that the exact same
thing as you know a founder of ripple or
the founder of the XRP ledger who's
selling some XRP I'm not disputing the
kind of I think and I don't know who
asked the question but I'm not disputing
that okay if we looked holistically
about the introduction of supply
of XRP ripple is one component of it
mm-hmm I think about ripples
participation in the increase of supply
equal to the mining increase an increase
of supply of eath or Bitcoin okay
because eath has a whole bunch of I mean
non mining related supply that's
introduced right yeah so does Bitcoin so
does XR P I so and I'm not trying to
dodge the question I'm just saying that
like the question applies to well I
guess the question is on more market cap
specific cap is I think there's two
components this one is included in the
market cap is tokens that are held by
restrictive selling agreements right
well I think that's really referring to
one of the co-founders the XRP ledger
and the cofounders of ripples a guy
named Jed McCaleb Jed had threatened but
didn't just threaten he said he was
going to dump all his XRP he was trying
to mean he had left rippling he's trying
to start a competitor ripple called
stellar and he said he's gonna dump this
there was a court activity and a
settlement it's it restricted his
ability to sell because he was trying to
act in a you know not in a good way to
the market got it into I'm kind of
jumping running a little bit gently
related to this when you guys sell
ripple OTC XRP or I'm sorry XRP do you
guys put restricted selling agreements
on anyone who buys OTC sometimes yes
sometimes it largely depends I mean look
if somebody it came to us well keep in
mind by the way we the amount of OTC
we're doing now is dramatically less we
were before for the reasons we kind of
talked about before you know if somebody
was coming to us and saying I would buy
twenty million dollars of XRP you know
there is a risk as someone would want to
do that and somehow we have ill intent
and so we might have restrictions on
that you know they're also back to the
Wales point you know and you could argue
actually what ripple has done is
healthier than what you have in the eath
environment or Bitcoin because there are
no restrictions now I think it in all of
these environments people are probably
acting in the best interests because
you're generally right unless you're
irrational or not very smart would there
be a way for you to
in I'll caveat again sitting as a person
trying to understand how you guys are
thinking about this and also
understanding kind of the other side
there's sensitivities whenever you're
doing business transactions with I'll
call them customers or partners whoever
and so you don't want to you know open
source your contracts right for example
right but is there a wave to feeling
more transparent is kind of a negative
connotation but just more transparent
around what those selling restrictions
are either on a customer basis or on a
more kind of generalized basis I mean
here's kind of my R axis okay so we're
already ten or a hundred times more
transparent than anybody the crypto
community and we get attacked for doing
that and I think you just asked them to
be more transparent I think I'm gonna
pass yeah I mean yeah it's just kind of
like like what we are doing what we
think are smart strategic things to
leverage our balance sheet in a way that
we think is rational and thoughtful
about catalyzing this whole area mm-hmm
am I going to you know share our you
know the formula of like here's how
we're doing things I mean is it that
secret and special yeah we can debate
that but like this is actually here's
what I'll say this is one thing where if
people were in there actually are some
people who want you guys to do this
right said basically open source the
contracts all right like show us exactly
what every single contract looks with
every single customer I actually think
that's like pretty far overkill right
just given that you're trying to run a
business so I'll definitely and also if
I may I think one of the challenges for
how capitalism has evolved period is we
were very short-term centric I have been
very public and saying look I'm taking a
very long view of the company we're
trying to create and you know if I
pissed some people off in the short term
I'm okay with that I I think I think you
know I didn't talk about it earlier but
I was in business school when Jeff Bezos
is 1996 Jeff Bezos he hadn't really
launched Amazon he came to my class and
I sex talked about Amazon it was Amazon
books really and he talked about it
since that I've been an amber
my classmates ended up working at Amazon
and I've been kind of enamored watching
the company and I think what they have
done has been very very impressive in
lots of ways but one of the things I
have looked at it I think about ripple
is to cross-border payments as Amazon is
to books okay you gotta explain that
Amazon Amazon launched one vertical
books had they not succeeded in books
they never would have able to DVDs or
music or you know now AWS right AWA
right that's the infrastructure level
what I think about ripples doing there's
a lot of different applications of
blockchain technologies there's a lot of
different ways we can use the XRP ledger
we started at the vertical around
cross-border payments partly because
it's a massive market partly because
it's a very clear pain point you have
customers who don't like the incumbents
they're happy to engage but what I've
said to the company is look we have to
be successful in books
aka cross-border payments or we don't
get permission to go to the second
vertical but ultimately I see what
ripples doing with blockchain
technologies as we're gonna enter other
verticals for sure what it will will
they be oh my gosh I should open source
that to just throw it out there that
that would be another type that you
would enter I I mean look we have you're
a master at dodging I appreciate it
that's what we're looking at lots of
different things other types of
financial services I'll give you another
interesting example real quickly do you
know who the largest investor was in
pets.com it went bankrupt
I do not Amazon really the owners I'd
point that out is look we have made a
bunch of investments in other projects
going on out there I think right now
ripple is the largest investor in crypto
period we've invested about five hundred
million dollars in other crypto projects
I'm sorry we're gonna make a bunch of
investments a lot of different things
some of them unrelated to the XRP world
some very related some related ripple
some unrelated some related payments
some unrelated some of those may be
things that we end up buying some of
those maybe end up things that we invest
anyway yeah great my point to some
degree is in the nascent stage of a
market and watching Amazon lose money on
pets.com
that was totally okay right you know
that they were learning as they went and
we're gonna do the same thing there will
certainly be other verticals that we go
after a triple and I'm not even sure how
I got in this topic that's good that's
that's the point of why I'm here
just to lead you with bread good we
asked me a question that somehow I got
on Amazon I'm not sure right so as part
of this one of the things that also
comes up in the sales I think it's last
question on sales is how do you think
about when you sell OTC right so there's
the restrictive of selling agreements
then there's some sort of discounting at
time sometimes not talk just about
generally not okay generally not when
there is is it hey if you lock this up
there's a discount or kind of how do you
think about from a framework standpoint
first I mean look so first of all
generally there is not okay to the
extent there is it's hey we're doing a
bigger broader deal in some construct
and we're thinking a lot of different
you know how do we create value on both
sides in a lot of different pieces and
this is likely would it be fair to say
the discounted OTC sales are not with
the crypto speculators they're more with
customers and partners correct okay and
what would a for sure correct a better a
bigger deal would be and but this is me
just completely speculating making this
up but I think generally if I'm sitting
in your seat it's something like hey
you're gonna be a customer of our
software product we're going to also
give you some XR PE for liquidity
purposes or whatever you can basically
buy it at some discount and then you can
hold me about cheating or we'll loan it
to you and you know at a very low
interest rate or you know I mean it
there's different mechanisms right okay
we're trying to be thoughtful and
creative about how we catalyze the whole
marketplace and you know like there are
the good news for us is those other
companies in the XRP world who are doing
similar things they're just not as big
as we are their own as much XRP but
there's a lot of other cool stuff going
on and I guess that's good for everybody
yeah and by the way I don't think that
doing that is wrong right I mean look
everyone there's people who I said I
sell things and I discount them so like
I understand um what do you think the
average discount is oh I mean like 50
percent oh no I was five I mean like I
don't know smaller numbers yeah right I
mean look I I think about XRP as a
currency mm I should I mean would you
sell a dollar if it was my sessions is
well that was we weren't any questions
do you think it's a currency you'd eat
it look at it more of like a utility
toka how do you think about it I mean I
you know part of the question there's
like I don't know what's exactly the
utility token what I mean there's some
parts you're starting to sound like me
III don't even know look what I do know
what maybe for better for worse in 2015
we had a FinCEN settlement with the
government
okay the US government called XRP a
currency okay I think of it as a
currency for purposes of deals like what
you're describing I think of it as a
currency and so if I were thinking about
a a deal construct and back to the whole
reason we're talking about this is that
did the discount point I wouldn't I
wouldn't give dollars away for for a
half dollars right would I give someone
a advantageous deal denominated in
dollars for some reason sure mm-hmm that
makes sense okay so let's go to x RP r
me in terms of all of the engagement on
Twitter yeah you're not the x RP army
commander what do you that what is your
reaction been to this what is kind of
your in perspective on kind of how it
enthusiastic people are online
look III love the fact that there's a
group of people who believe in what
we're doing are advocating and if
anything I actually think the X RPG army
is a reaction to the aggressiveness of
the FUD interesting elaborate on this
well I think people are that they're
sometimes more than other times people
are putting out information that is
factually incorrect either about ripple
or about the XRP ledger or about the
people around the ecosystem or about
other companies in the ecosystem and you
know that that community has been
catalyzed to correct that and in that
context I think that's awesome
you know it are they a more vibrant
group than others I don't know I look I
get attacked by plenty who are outside
of that army those are pretty active
people too I think the whole space is
super engaged right and then there in
some ways that's a beautiful healthy
thing but look can we all start with the
same basis of facts and and you know I
think some people just stop listening in
a way that I find to be you know
frustrating and I'm still learning we
should all still learn there's things
that I don't fully understand abouts go
on a Bitcoin world there's things I
learned in the conference in Montreal I
found super interesting but there's a
lot of myths and misunderstandings about
what ripple is about what the xrp ledger
is how it works and you know I look as I
said I'm here today to try to correct
the record on some of those things for
sure I only got a couple more questions
if we get a wrap-up but good um in terms
of payment to employees
one of things I find fascinating is
there's plenty of companies that are
built around Bitcoin employees accept
Bitcoin as their salary by Nan's B&B
right are there folks at ripple slash
XRP that are working on this and getting
paid in XRP well you'll /xf e there's
employees at ripple who choose to get
paid in XRP yes okay got it
I don't think anybody gets paid a
hundred percent and XRP but it's a you
know it's a kind of an opt-in and we may
limit the amount that percentage they
can take an extra fee I'm not sure got
it all right so last stop I want to
cover I call this like the elephant in
the room and it's more from my
standpoint one of the things that we did
not do as investors is we did not
participate in the whole ICO stuff right
and for us it was more around alcohol
regulatory uncertainty right and for us
it was we had so many opportunities on
the equity side where we could go invest
it was just like and we don't really
have an advantage there so right we'll
leave for other people what's your
perspective on tokens regulation there's
been a bunch of settlement recently
they've been a now it's kind of at the
end of the the fiscal year for the sec
etc with a OS and block one and all that
kind of just fraud based first just like
how do you view this whole environment
given that you've actually working on
this for you know what four or five
years now you've kind of seen some
evolutions there what's your perspective
like I think if you go back and look at
my Twitter feed you will find that I was
one of the first people to come out and
say I think this whole I see are things
getting in badly really I think you go
back and look I was I was very early and
same danger danger I said that kudos to
you I was on a panel and I remember this
well as an MIT panel and I tell you that
there was like eight hundred people
showed up to this thing in San Francisco
is a massive audience it was a riot at
the height of the ico market okay I
remember there's a lawyer sitting next
to me who's kind of ADD
Katie yeah I do an ICO and I all I said
was if you're gonna do an ICO just
remember to hold back a lot of that
money to pay him as a lawyer to defend
you and the sec comes after you now one
of the things I was point out is an
interesting irony about this whole thing
is we a triple and even I think the XRP
community kind of leaned out during that
craze and eath community leaned in to
really enable though that the ICO craze
isn't it ironic that by doing that eath
was then deemed not to be a security
given its distribution and the SEC
hasn't said anything but XRP okay we
decided that hey look we think that that
actually clearly you know ripple didn't
do a nice ear the XRP ledger predated
Ripple how did it was there a
quote-unquote ICO for XR p on the XR p
ledger no the early days expert village
were giveaways ripple the company raised
money through venture capital and it
seriousiy financing in a series a
financing a series be financing got it
what have you and so I gotta ask
XRP there's plenty people with these
security point people who don't I think
uh supply people who don't okay I mean
look there's a I don't know exactly the
name of it this ranking system that came
out this week the cooker rating yeah did
you read my notes before this so what my
question is this is literally gonna be
if you look at those rankings compared
to others
you guys actually scored pretty well
right and then I think that the big
question and I'm very sensitive the fact
that I don't you to say anything that
you're uncomfortable saying but at the
same time how do you think about if
you're sitting in the regulators seat
deciding what's the security what's not
this stuff's new you spoke about eath
transitioning possibly from could have
been a security to now it's not just
talk a little bit about that you know
sitting running what what do you guys
have her fourth largest kappa asset now
depends recount market cap i think the
SEC has a really hard job and I've
genuinely agreed that like this is a new
thing you know what is it me how should
it be regulated and so I'm respectful of
fact that it's some of the stuff it's
not black and white I think that you
know how that plays out is I think yet
to be determined I think the slowly but
surely SEC is providing more guidance
both throughout what they're doing with
an enforcement mechanism and what
they're doing you know kind of what
they're publishing on policy stuff you
know we work with regulators around the
world you know some regulators have been
much kind of quicker than the US has
about being specific yeah the UK has
come out and said they've uxr peeing the
same thing as ethan BTC we've seen a
bunch of other you know the japan that
has been true so you know III can't
certainly speak on behalf of the sec
suffice to say i think they've got a
hard job and i understand that yeah
they're kind of trying to do their best
to work through it before we wrap up I
always ask two questions oh you get
asked me one question that ended but my
two questions most important book you've
ever read uh we just went from debating
of securities law to now favorite book
Snow Crash snow karo they old school so
there's three books that are given to
product managers when they joined
Facebook it's no crashes one of them
really I didn't know that yeah if I
actually forget the other I was giving
Snow Crash and some around 95 96 and I
thought pretty is pretty fascinating
yeah it for those that read it I think a
lot of people receive it never read it
but those who read it is pretty good
aliens believer or non-believer for sure
why there's too many things out there
that says it's a law of large numbers if
they showed up to the US would that be a
good or I'm sorry to the earth would
that be a good or bad thing oh we should
we have aliens here already for sure
have you been outside in New York City
okay how about that so Brett Brad
actually with the area 51 all right my
one question for you is do you think
differently about ripple and the XRP
ledger now as compared to 60 70 80
minutes somewhere along we've been here
so I will I'm gonna expertly dodge that
only because I think most people
actually don't know what I thought
before you walked in you know that's
fair well I just asked if you thought
differently yeah yeah so I think I'm
actually on the podcast on record saying
that it's important to separate out
software company from XRP I actually
think that having software that makes
banks run better there's big businesses
to be built that right we've actually
invested in a bunch of businesses that
either trying to disrupt software
products that are currently in banks or
or helping banks
be more efficient that all makes a lot
of sense to me XRP my only big thing
that I just can't get over right and I
understand the academic or I understand
the argument as to why is if you can use
XRP right across the rails when I use
Bitcoin now I think your argument would
be volatility the I can't stop it all
the thing it's a lot faster and a lot
cheaper to use XR for you so what I end
up coming to is there are - there's
probably many versions of the future but
two of those versions are what I will
call a corporate company creating a
software product that is then sold in an
enterprise model into banks which you
guys are doing and there is likely to be
something other than Bitcoin that's used
so whether that's XRP or somebody else
comes along and creates something or
it's Libra or you know whatever whatever
it gets created with the white paper we
notice I didn't even go there yeah we're
not going there all right and then the
other world is a world of Bitcoin which
yeah there will be people who build this
stuff but it's much more kind of
empowering people it's fighting back
against things like inflation the
banking system yada yada yada I really
do think that what ends up being the
most valuable is which path the world
goes down right that's fair like I don't
think that it is a if we go down the
path where we need something that is
fully decentralized non-central
non-seasonal etc like I don't think that
ripple and XRP end up being the winner
right in that world vice versa if we go
down a world where we need a corporate
software company that sells into banks
etc like I actually don't think that
Bitcoin can win in that world there's an
expression that I use sometimes at work
much to the frustration of riffle
employees it's the tyranny on the
tyranny of the or versus the power of
the end so why is it one or the other of
those I think there's kind of any I know
we're wrapping up but you know I think
one of the mistakes that people make in
this kind of broader or crypto world is
there's not gonna be one winner here
there's gonna be a bunch of interesting
winners and about I you know I would
even yield the point is the XRP
environment clear
gonna be winter you know I think there's
mentioning dynamics there that make it
more efficient in a whole bunch of ways
but I think it did the other day comes
back to like is it salt are these
technologies being used to solve a real
problem for real customers in a scaled
way and there's a lot of a long way to
go in all of them one sentence answer at
the end of this whenever you go do
whatever you go do next it could be 30
years from now what is the legacy that
you want ripple XRP and Bitcoin to leave
on the world I hope that these
technologies put a little dent in the
universe in terms of making commerce
more efficient I think that's completely
fair all right listen you get a lot of
credit for for coming and doing this
completely blind so I appreciate very
much and where can people find you on
the Internet at be Garlin house Twitter
app eagerly knows the XRP are me the
lovers the detractors have added alright
guys thanks so much thanks Bob hey
everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain
you